y a pas plus intelligent plus malin il
ya mois puis obélix par exemple tiens
vendait londinium
tout à coup on était poursuivi par des
romains il fallait absolument cacher un
tonneau de potion magique mais où est
tout à coup c'est à féchy là dedans
réfléchissez un peu je me suis dit bas
par exemple si je devais cacher un arbre
le meilleur endroit c'est maintenant une
forêt d'agre beaucoup d'armes autour
comme ça on trouve bello fille je vais
faire pareil que tous nos jeux mais le
caché dans une forêt nous berges non
dans une forêt tu me dit non parce que
il n'y a pas d'autres tenues dans la
forêt oncy jusqu'à château ne se soit
tout de suite
justement c'est parce que ça se voit
qu'ils voient pas
je ne me mary teuw le vous le cacher une
forêt pas facile tous les jours